[Música]
cuál es la principal causa de muerte en
méxico
estoy empezando con una pregunta
horrible pero
cuáles podrían ser de entrada podrían
ser los accidentes automovilísticos
después de todo todos parecemos conocer
a alguien que ha estado inmerso en
alguno
11.000 muertos el año pasado
tal vez es algo más grave más letal como
el narcotráfico méxico es la tercera
zona en mayor conflicto armado del mundo
justo abajo de siria y afganistán
12000 muertos el año pasado
pero no por desgracia la respuesta
correcta es algo mucho más sencillo pero
14 veces más letal
y estamos hablando de la obesidad a
través de sus efectos por supuesto
tenemos una urgencia por encontrar una
forma de que menos gente muera por esto
y lo producto es que ya conocemos la
cura una dieta balanceada
y una vida activa deportivamente
hablando
sin embargo en cuanto a este aspecto una
vida deportiva encontramos un problema
grave y es de percepción creemos que los
deportes son una opción más que una
obligación y si no me lo creen a mí
pregúntaselo a mi maestra de secundaria
que por no entender la utilidad de ir a
una olimpiada nacional de esgrima
prefirió reprobar me pregúntenselo a los
padres de mis compañeros de esgrima o de
thai cuando castigo favorito quitarles
el entrenamiento pregúntaselo ustedes
mismos cuando pagan todo el año del
gimnasio y no van un solo día
cómo van esos kilitos de año nuevo
bueno pero si quisiéramos decir que el
deporte es una obligación primero
tendríamos que definir las dos cosas
primero el deporte es una actividad
física que se practica en comunidad y
que tiene un conjunto de reglas
actividad física comunidad
estoy dejando afuera
un elemento importante que es la
competencia ahí no me malentiendan la
competencia es un gran elemento del
deporte nos enseña al esfuerzo de
competitividad de trabajo en equipo sin
embargo si vamos a plantear el deporte
como una obligación lo primero que
tendríamos que hacer es entender que no
todos somos buenos en el deporte no
todos nos encanta practicar deporte pero
realmente eso no importa porque esta
obligación no está compuesta de medallas
esta obligación está compuesta
simplemente de hacerlo constantemente y
en cuanto a una obligación basta decir
que hay dos tipos de obligaciones están
las estatales aquellas que el estado te
impone como pagar tus impuestos como
darle comer a tus hijos pero también las
6 sociales cómo tratar con respeto a los
demás
no hay ninguna ley que me diga que yo no
tengo que tratar con respeto pero
francamente prefiero no ser un lote de
c's así que vamos tratando nos bien
en cuanto a las obligaciones tienen un
elemento común -todas y es que todas
tienen un beneficio social las
consideramos obligatorias precisamente
porque mejoran a nuestra sociedad
cuáles son los beneficios sociales del
deporte
bueno entrada está el obvio el deporte
cura y previene la obesidad eso que es
la primera causa no sólo de méxico sino
del mundo de muerte el deporte lo
arregla también mejora nuestro cuerpo en
sentido de que mejora la circulación los
huesos las articulaciones y libera una
hormona maravillosa nuestra cabeza que
se llama la dopamina ésta ayuda a
mejorar nuestra autoestima estar más
felices en la vida en general
tanto este efecto se siente en el cuerpo
como se siente en el bolsillo de hecho
un estudio en eeuu que estaba siguiendo
cuánto es el ahorro promedio de
deportistas al hacer deporte en aspectos
de salud encontró después de buscar
después seguir a 26.000 personas que por
cada media hora de caminata que se haga
el día cinco días a la semana
el ahorro promedio es de 2500 dólares
estamos hablando de 50 mil pesos al año
en doctores simplemente por caminar al
trabajo este efecto por supuesto que se
hace más grande a nivel estatal de hecho
josé antonio casajús investigador de la
universidad de zaragoza menciona que por
cada euro que se invierte en deporte se
puede esperar un ahorro de seis euros en
el sistema de salud
solo por hacer más deporte y este
beneficio no es más para las personas
mayores de 45 años puesto que son las
que están en mayor riesgo
sin embargo también el deporte tiene
beneficios para los jóvenes en
específico en dos áreas paz e inclusión
social otro estudio esta vez en
inglaterra que siguió un grupo de
jóvenes durante varios años para buscar
una correlación entre la práctica de
deporte y la criminalidad encontró que
si aumentan 10% la práctica deportiva se
disminuye 1.56 por ciento la
criminalidad ahora tal vez este número
suene poco pero si hubiéramos agarrado
este número y lo hubiéramos aplicado
sólo con los delitos denunciados el año
pasado
habríamos tenido un ahorro de dos mil
delitos anual de dos mil delitos en todo
el sexenio
estamos diciendo que solo por practicar
deporte habría menos homicidios
violaciones secuestros y esto porque
aparte de los beneficios físicos y
psicológicos para la juventud tiene otro
aspecto poco menos esperado entre más
deporte se haga se disminuye el grado de
falta escolar y el grado de abandono
escolar más deporte más escuela para los
jóvenes un último beneficio que me
gustaría mencionar es el económico
aparte de los beneficios de ahorro de
salud también el deporte tiene una
tendencia a crear
toda una economía a su alrededor de
hecho esta economía es tan grande que en
hong kong el año pasado generó el 2 por
ciento de su producto interno bruto algo
así como 26 mil millones de dólares y no
estamos hablando ni de olimpiadas ni de
mundiales simplemente estamos hablando
de gente que practica deporte ahora si
resumimos los beneficios sociales en
salud paz y economía
podríamos todos estar de acuerdo que el
deporte tiene muchos más beneficios de
lo que cuesta
como estamos en mexico
una respuesta corta es mal la respuesta
larga es que el inegi hace una encuesta
para determinar cuál es el índice de
participación deportiva de los mexicanos
el 42% de nosotros hicimos deporte el
año pasado de este 42% sólo la mitad
hizo deporte suficiente 8 de cada 10
mexicanos no hace suficiente deporte
para ser saludable
es una cifra horrible y todavía se
vuelve peor cuando vemos quiénes son los
grupos que menos deporte practican
encontramos que los hombres hacen más
deporte que las mujeres 49 a 36 por
ciento encontramos que entre menos
educación tienes menos deporte prácticas
y entre más edad tienes menos deporte
prácticas
y si nos basamos en los beneficios que
acabo de mencionar esto empieza a sonar
congruente entre más beneficios tiene
para un grupo de personas menos ese
grupo de personas lo practican mujeres
estudiantes personas mayores de 45 años
pero porque no lo practican mismo inegi
nos da las respuestas la primera opción
con 50 por ciento de aceptación es que
les falta tiempo después nos vamos a un
30 por ciento con esto demasiado cansado
por el trabajo y un 10% porque tienen
alguna lesión ellos iban a ser campeones
mundiales pero se jodieron la rodilla
después ya sé lo que están pensando hay
otra razón otras dos razones por las que
no hacemos deporte una de ellas es la
flojera 4% y la última la falta economía
3% si las juntamos 7% son
estadísticamente irrelevantes pero las
primeras dos opciones nos cuentan otra
historia ahora una historia de índole
laboral y es que méxico es uno de los
países con menos vacaciones del mundo
justo ahí con japón y china- la verdad
nada glorioso para ser cierto porque
también nuestros índices de
productividad están por los suelos pero
no es ningún hilo negro que no sabemos
menos productividad quiere decir que
vamos a tener que trabajar más tiempo lo
cual nos quita tiempo para actividades
como el deporte lo cual baja la moral y
por tanto baja la productividad es un
auténtico círculo vicioso
aquí otro aspecto donde el deporte nos
puede apoyar y es que por dar un ejemplo
un armador automotriz en eeuu después de
poner un programa deportivo en 130
establecimientos encontró que disminuía
la tasa de accidentes laborales y
aumentaba la productividad laboral
literalmente les hacía más dinero del
que les costaba el programa deportivo
hoy oscar solamente en eeuu pasa esto
por supuesto que no en méxico hay desde
mineras hasta despachos de abogados que
tienen un programa deportivo y que bien
hacen por sus negocios
y un último aspecto que me gustaría
tocar este es el aspecto que todos
tenemos el aspecto político es común ver
presupuestos que no llegan a deportistas
leyes que no se cumplen
una ausencia total y absoluta de un plan
nacional deportivo que de hecho abarque
a toda la comunidad
y esto se siente en méxico
pero no vengo hablarle ni a diputados ni
a políticos ni a presidentes de
federaciones hoy vengo a hablarles a
ustedes hablarte a ti porque este
problema a diferencia de tantos otros
problemas que existen en el mundo está
en nuestras manos resolver si no haces
deporte es tan sencillo como terminando
el télex vaya si averigües cual deporte
te gusta que importa si es olímpico que
importa si está solamente en tu colonia
lo único que importa es que lo
practiques más de tres horas a la semana
para tener beneficios si eres padre tu
obligación doble porque aparte de tener
que ser algún modelo a seguir de tus
hijos tienes que enseñarlos y motivarlos
a que escojan su propio deporte
no los castigue si hacen algún berrinche
quitándoles el entrenamiento sería igual
a que si los castigará quitándoles la
escuela no le estás enseñando nada y
solamente lo estás afectando y por
último si tienes alguna compañía a una
empresa o alguna institución considera
un programa deportivo si tienes un
programa deportivo tus colaboradores van
a estar más motivados y tus ventas van a
aumentar literalmente es una inversión
porque genera más de lo que cuesta
ahora ya sé que suena como un regaño ni
un enojado pero vamos a pensar una cosa
yo toda mi vida he sido deportista nunca
fue un olímpico nunca estuve en alto
rendimiento
simplemente practico todos los días
deporte y durante dos años que no lo
hice como sufrí perjuicios a mi salud
he dicho muchísimas cifras estadísticas
y estudios el día de hoy para tratar de
convencerlos de que el deporte es algo
que nos puede dar muchísimos beneficios
pero si se van a quedar con algo de esta
práctica solamente quédense con esta
cifra por cada hora que hacen de deporte
le están agregando 2 horas y media a su
vida déjenme repetirlo si hacen ustedes
una hora de deporte
en promedio van a vivir dos horas y
media más el deporte no es una pérdida
de tiempo es el regalo más valioso que
le puedes dar a tus hijos es el regalo
más valioso que te puedes dar a ti mismo
es momento de dejar de interpretar al
deporte como una opción y eso hay que
cambiarlo por un derecho por una
obligación incluso el deporte es nuestra
obligación para con nosotros para con la
sociedad para con nuestros hijos y para
con nuestros empleados hagamos todos
deporte seamos más parte de la solución
que del problema
[Aplausos]